beer me what's it
hand me that water I always say beer me
gets a laugh like a quarter of the time
so how's what's-her-name
you knew her name who Karen yeah she's
only want to mail his friends how's the
apartment hanging it's fine yes
check out this sunshine man global
warming right today was supposed to be
really cold I bet what about music
give me music ah yeah she said so right
at dinner to give me the beat boys and
free my soul I wanna get lost in your
rock and roll and drift away hey we did
to do but didn't they don't ever give me
bars and free my little oh so don't sing
more like a scene here a CD your call
did my girlfriend made an awesome mix
beer me that disc Lauren beer me
strength so tuna when we get in there
let's do a really good job okay did that
really need to be said well not
everything guys says needs to be said
sometimes just about the music of a
conversation whoa why is my girlfriend
here
oh she's that teacher in the white no
she's a part-time frozen yogurt chef
which one is she the one in the green
hoodie Wow wonder she's like a guidance
counselor sup no calling so it's like
probably a tutor know she probably now
oh and you know what we don't have a lot
of time so we should probably J Mandy Oh
what are you doing here Andy are you
student here
oh yeah you never told me you were in
high school this is weird I got a go to
Spanish oh my god oh my god I had no
idea well that's not gonna hold up in
court
huh we didn't do anything illegal except
knock over in mailbox with her friends
I'll be with you in a moment all right
who was that guy she was talking to at
her locker not important because you're
not dating here because it's Melanie but
who was that probably another high
school student
the issue with the watermark is very
serious absolutely we teach our students
that character counts should you don't
teach it well enough when your students
is a yeah chandi is having a real rough
day today I want to take up an ad in
your yearbook full-page two words
good luck that's not what I had in mind
you want music I don't care
come on man just do it a couple days I
think you'll be alright yeah
and we move it only moment we are we
oh wait you know I'm right on the wing
move it shall we mow it a wimoweh a
wimoweh a wimoweh a wimoweh a wimoweh
[Music]
you